Hello,
and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode live.
I am your host Rawkode.
Today is our seventh episode of clustered,
a
show in which
me and I guess will attempt to fix
broken Kubernetes clusters. The catch is these clusters
are broken by members of our community
and sometimes they're nice to us and sometimes
they're downright evil. No idea what we're gonna
expect today, but hopefully it will be educational
and fun for all. Now before we get
started and I introduce today's guest, please remember
to subscribe to the YouTube channel and click
the bell. You will get alerts for every
episode of clustered as well as all the
other educational materials that I'm putting out there
in the cloud native landscape.
I would also encourage you to join the
Discord. We're doing something a little bit different
today. If you're on the Discord, there is
a Discord stage, a feature which launched yesterday.
People in there can communicate and discuss the
episode live over audio.
And if we get stuck during today's episode,
we are gonna go to the audience for
some help. So get in there, get involved.
Also, I'd love to thank my employer. They
allow me to spend time and energy and
compute resources
putting these educational materials together. So thank you
to Equinix Medal. If you wanna check out
Equinix Medal, you can use a coupon code,
which will get you $50, which is around
one hundred hours of compute.
That code is Rawkode9.
Awesome. That is the housekeeping done. Now, I
can introduce today's wonderful guest. I am joined
by Guinevere Zinger. Hi, Guinevere. How are you?
Hey. Good morning from Seattle.
I'm doing well today. Thanks. Thanks for having
me. How are you? Yes.
I'm very well, but as always, I'm clustered,
slightly scared, worried, paranoid, and excited all in
one rolled up into a ball.
So you're I don't think you need an
introduction. Everyone is familiar with you in the
Kubernetes community. Why
don't you give us the well, give us
the TLDR and anything else that you wanna
share, and then we'll move on and get
started on today's clusters.
I am the loud, bouncy one that asks
all the questions.
So
I'm
I don't know everything about Kubernetes.
Some people think I do. I
I
I usually know who to ask for help.
I consider that my secret power, and I
just I'm here to share that it's okay
to not know everything and learn together and
find out.
So,
that's
that's I think. That's me.
Yeah. I live at Seattle,
which is beautiful
right now. We have awesome spring weather, mountains
on three sides when we all can. Again,
you should all come visit.
It's
I yeah. I have a kiddo.
He's maybe going to poke in his head
at some point.
And,
yeah, I'm really excited. I've I've not watched
one of these before, so
I'm
I'm I'm gonna be like, wait. How does
this work?
And
yeah. I'm I'm I'm looking at this and
I'm I'm really excited. I love pair programming,
so pair debugging is my next favorite thing.
Well,
yeah. We'll be We'll
be doing a lot of debugging. I'm pretty
sure.
Like I said, we have two broken clusters.
We're gonna
use teleport. We're gonna pair in the same
session. We're gonna work out what's wrong and
hopefully
we're gonna fix it.
I love that you said, know, you wanna
show people that you don't have to know
everything.
I feel like I've done a sterling job
of that in the first six episodes. I
have
I've definitely shown that you know, you can
work in this space for a long time
and work with Kubernetes daily. There's still things
that catch me every single time and I
think that's true for everybody. Right? We wanna
set new norms that you don't know everything
and then it's just about experience and learning
together.
It's awesome. Yeah.
Yeah. I mean, what was it? Yesterday? No.
Two days ago, I learned that the default
back off limit on jobs is six.
I learned that the hard way.
I kept waiting for my job to fail
and it didn't.
Well, there you go. Today, I've learned that
as well. So Right? We've already started off
on the right foot, which is exactly what
we want.
Alright.
Let's well you've not seen this before so
like,
I mean you don't know what all the
other breaks that people have been quite evil
about. So we're gonna we're really gonna see
today whether these people like us or not.
So we should introduce our first broken cluster.
So we're gonna start with cluster 14 today,
which is broken by Phil,
Phil Weltz, who is a member of the
Discord community, active on Twitter,
and
as European. So we offered to do this
cluster first so that you can spend a
little time with us and hopefully give us
any advice if required.
Well, when required, let's just put that out
there already.
Now, let me pop open my screen share.
We
are now floating bubbles. We have our teleport.
I'm gonna jump on to the control plane
node of cluster 14. I will zoom in
just a smidgen and if you can just
join that and type echo hello or something
so we know your web is and we
will get started.
As always audience, please feel free to leave
your YouTube comments for anything that we missed,
things you want us to check. If you're
in the Discord
stage,
we will try and get you involved as
well as we get started.
So,
how is your session looking?
I might not have joined your session.
Let's
see. Let me disconnect
active
sessions.
Options.
Root session is in progress.
I'll
join yours.
I joined my own session.
That was smart of me.
Right. Well, Fell assures us to that he
has treated the cluster kindly.
We are gonna find out.
What normally what I would do first here
is just kinda get a set up. Well
first I always do my alias otherwise I'm
gonna type that 14,000 times and get that
wrong. The other thing I wanna do is
Sorry.
So that we don't have to specify dash
dash kube config every fourteen seconds, I will
just export that too. So now, in theory,
we can run k get notes. I'll let
you jump in and get that done, and
we'll see if Fella's kind enough to leave
us an API server.
That
rarely ever happens.
Maybe, you know, maybe this cluster isn't broken
and it's an April fool's joke.
We've broken something, but we will so do
our best to give this cluster a little
bit of diligence and see if we can
find something that is wrong.
Now because you've not seen this before, I'll
just kinda run through the objectives.
Normally, in our default namespace, we would have
a couple of workloads.
An application that has a little video of
me pointing to my watch going we better
fix this. It would appear we don't have
said workload.
So we'll need to work that one out
first. Although I'm curious about the Postgres
zero.
So it looks like we do have the
database, but we don't have the web application.
And normally, I'd want to deploy an upgrade
to the application, which schedules a new shiny
video of me dancing, but we're not in
a position to do that yet.
Let's see if we have pods hiding in
other namespaces,
though. Yeah. Go for it.
Oopsies.
I could type in front of people. Oh,
yeah. Did I fail to mention that?
So
there's a
bunch more stuff.
Yeah.
It looks
Let's see. One of the staff pods Oh,
no.
Appears to be hanging.
I'm just gonna run that again because my
scroll seems to there we go. Scrolls running.
Good.
Yeah. Okay. Awesome.
So there's a Cilium operator
that's been going on that is in a
Cilium namespace.
I don't even know what Cilium is, so
that's cool.
Cilium is the CNI plugin that we use
on these clusters.
Awesome. So and then, Qiverno,
also of interest.
That one looks like it was installed
eighteen hours ago, so that's different. I don't
know. Again, I don't know what that is.
And and
then we have a hanging
two minutes thirty six seconds.
Okay.
Also, of the operators had some restarts.
Oh gosh. The CSI plugin has been restarted
17 times,
14 times. Okay.
There might be some clues there.
Yeah. Definitely.
I think we have to follow, I guess
what if a bread crumb. Right? The only
container in this entire cluster which is not
currently running is our Rookseth detect version
is stuck on a in a container step.
So I reckon we're gonna have to get
some logs out of there.
The Kivernal that you're not familiar with is
a
policy agent
which probably has some admission controllers in the
system that we wanna take a look at
later. That definitely is new. I did not
deploy Kivernal to these clusters.
So I think we we pointed that out.
Qyvernal sounds like the main character in a
high fantasy novel.
Like, you know, winter is coming,
but where Qyvernal's
curse? I I
don't I actually have never
I have avoided
Game of Thrones
for its entire existence, so maybe I shouldn't
make jokes about it.
Let's see. Okay. So
where is my prompt? I think I lost
my prompt somehow. Nope. There it is. I
had a scroll. Excellent.
Let's
get some logs out of there.
K. Log. Is it log or logs? I
always forget. I think it's logs. I tend
to use logs.
But you'll need to specify the names.
Okay.
It's waiting to start pod initializing.
What happens if we, like
So if we wanna get the edit container
log, we'll need to provide the name of
the container. So we're probably gonna have to
Oh, wait. Describe it and see what's actually
going on in that back,
I think.
Okay.
Script
pod.
Cool.
Failed to set up network for sandbox.
Failed to find plug in cilium c and
I in path
up CNI bin, and there were a bunch
of restarts on that Cilium
container.
Yeah. That's weird. Why would
I'm not sure why our CSI
plug in
is
It's a CNI plug in.
They don't know what they have to Alright.
Okay. So the CNI can't send out the
sandbox for this. Okay.
Okay. So I think they've done I think
Phil has done something to our CNI. I'm
curious. How brave are you feeling?
I am terrified,
but that doesn't necessarily contradict the bravery. Do
we want to just like kick a pod?
Like kill it? Well, yeah. That's what I'm
thinking is I I
in order to confirm that this is not
related to Rawkode and Seth and this is
a CNI thing, I've got a funny suspicion
that if we kill any other pod, it
will also fail to star. It's kind of
what I'm thinking.
Interesting.
Yeah. Sure. Let's see. We have detect version.
That one is, like it's literally just detecting
a version.
Let's let's not kill the operator one.
What what what what's harmless. Which one do
you want which one do you wanna boot
out?
Let's kill one of the metal l b
speakers because we're not even using
load balancing. So
what is the what was that namespace called?
Metal l b Yeah. System.
Oh,
system delete
pod.
And then
Oh, it started just fine. It started.
Well,
let's take let's take a look at the
logs.
Yeah.
Sorry. I I guess I could type too.
Alright. We'll we'll we'll take our fair share
of typing.
That's that's all fine. No. Is that that
p g p Oh, yeah. No. That's true.
Yeah. It's okay. We can ignore that. That's
echoic thing.
So maybe
so it's the init container.
Right?
So it could be something Let me No.
On you go. What's your what's your train
of thought there? Let's take a look at
let's take a look at one of those,
like so we have the
CSI plug in. Wait. What's? Okay. So first
of all, what's the difference between CSI and
CNI?
Let's let's talk about it. There's too many
acronyms here.
Container system interface?
A storage. Storage
interface.
Okay. Thank you. And then container network interface.
Right? Yes. Correct. Okay. Those ones have seen
a bunch of restarts,
but
they're in the same but we might wanna
we might wanna describe one of those and
see why they got restarted so many times
because that might be related. So the Rawkode
namespace
seems to be having some trouble. Maybe there's
something messed up in the namespace.
The other thing that we might look at
is the operator logs.
Okay. So yeah. You're right. If we'll
the
14 restarts, five restarts, 17 restarts. Yeah. Maybe
there's something that is confined
this
Can we get the
previous logs for that pod?
We could. Although, we just had a spanner
thrown into our our hypothesis. Philip has commented
saying that he has not touched the CSI.
Okay.
Good. This is potentially just a red herring.
Alright. Alright.
Okay. I'm gonna
so there there should be a workload running
on our default namespace which hasn't Yes. I'm
gonna redeploy it.
Yep. Just to see if it works.
I'm gonna do that from my own machine
because that's just where the manifests are,
which I know you won't be able to
see, but I'll do
just
workload
and pop back over here.
Uh-huh.
So that was all unchanged.
I really hope I'm working on a rate
cluster.
But
we can't see anything.
So if we don't see pods,
I do expect to see
Alright.
We
have a deployment but we don't have pods.
Interesting.
I guess Yeah. Let's describe that deployment.
Let's
see.
Oh,
okay. Rolling update strategy,
25%
max unavailable.
Available false. Minimum replicas
unavailable.
Progress deadline exceeded
all the replica sets. Yeah. Okay.
We've got a couple of
failures here. It seems to be saying
I think it's unable to create the replica
sets.
Yeah.
I also
And
there's zero pods.
What if so we cannot
okay.
So we
try to redeploy this? Can we
So I think Can we do
Yeah. So we tried to redeploy it. It's
all unchanged. Right? It's the cluster thinks the
deployment is fine. It looks like we do
have the replica sets. We're not getting pods.
We did see the kivernal earlier. So I
think we're probably gonna wanna see what kivernal
has done to our cluster.
But I'm just gonna run and get events
and see. Yeah.
Uh-huh.
We've got a whole bunch of errors here.
Okay. And the mutating web configuration.
Always a pleasure. Conor ref invalid
namespace.
Okay.
So it's it looks like it's a permission
thing.
Does not exist in namespace
empty.
So we're in the default namespace, not the
namespace empty.
Empty string.
I I think.
Right? It's
I can't remember how long it's in space.
It's not something I've ever tested before. I
I think
I would hope. I don't even know. Maybe
an empty string should be default, but then
that error message makes it look pretty weird.
That error message makes it look like somebody
is just giving in a blank namespace.
Why don't we see if we can
what's the I can never remember it. It's
the cluster
Oh, no. API resources. Right?
We can also just get all.
I'm gonna grab that for mutating.
Yeah. There we go.
Let's let's see what is in our cluster.
These seem to be twenty six seconds old.
When we deploy. Wait.
That's
that's not when we deployed. That's, like, more
recent than that. That is more recent than
that.
Okay.
Let's describe these because these those are those
are, a little suspicious,
don't they?
I know nothing about admissions policy. I'm just
used to having permissions everywhere. Does not exist
in namespace
empty string.
So
Okay. So it looks like
a lot of noise,
but
Clients can fit.
Although the policy on this is ignored.
So even if this webhook failed.
Although I wonder if this is mutating the
namespace.
Interesting.
So
the owner ref
garbage garbage collector controller?
What happens if we delete the Qiverno
pod?
I think that's a great idea.
Kill it with fire.
We'll need to delete the mutating webhooks.
I mean, we can delete the kivernal part,
but I don't think it's
the mutating webhooks will still be there although
I guess the failure policy is
What do mutating webhooks even do?
I've I've gotta I've gotta
So gotta ask Google. What these do?
It just means that anytime that the API
server wants to create a new resource within
the cluster, it will send that request to
all of the Mutant Webhooks who can actually
modify that request and the cluster without us
knowing.
I suspect
what's happening here is that one of these
Mutant Webhooks is deleting the namespace
on all of the
pod objects, potentially.
So
I'm gonna say go away. Like, we do
not want any of these cavernal policies in
our cluster. Oh, thought I missed it. Yeah.
Oh, oh, not that shit.
We can give that a few seconds and
maybe we'll start getting a pod up.
We may have to actually
encourage that to happen. Why don't we delete
both the replica sets and try to speed
speed that up?
And hopefully the deployment controller will
yeah. There we go. There's a replica set.
Although we still don't have our pod.
Oh, well.
Do
okay.
So
can we describe the deploy again?
See what happened?
Should have some events.
Scaled up replica sets
to one.
Okay.
So So
So not quite an April fool, but Phil
has commented that he installed Hiverno just for
distraction.
Uh-huh. Nice.
Thanks, Phil. So
I'm looking at
I'm looking at some of this. So if
if we are having a replica set that
says we want this thing, but it's not
coming up
at all.
Well, Waleed At all at all. We're getting
a lot of comments from Waleed in the
chat. Shall we jump over and ask him
what he thinks?
Sure. Where are we jumping over to? Oh,
sorry. I'll I'll bring Waleed over here.
Waleed, do you wanna jump into the Discord
stage and we'll get your advice?
And she's right. I wish I knew exactly
how long the latency was between YouTube because
I could see that, and I don't know
if he's gonna hear it within one second
or, like, fourteen hours.
I'll
magic him along. So I see a failed
create for the replica set.
And then.
Oh, there's Walid. Replica failure.
Failed create.
Hey, Walid. Can you hear me?
Waleed.
I can hear you.
There we go.
Gwen, can you hear Waleed okay? Yes.
Alright. You were typing into the chat quite
a bit there. What are you suggesting we
look at next, Waleed?
I'm not sure because Phil says he installed
the Kiverna as a distraction.
I would like to check if there are
Kiverna policies.
So if you do okay, Kubectl
get the cluster policies or c port
to just
It looks like we have a cluster policy
called disallow privilege escalation.
I'm gonna assume unless
that has been very sneakily named in order
to take our attention away from it, but
that's probably unrelated.
Alright. Okay. The latency on YouTube and Discord
is a bit funky. So I'm just gonna
mute that now, and Gwen and I are
gonna march on.
Okay. Let's see.
So I'm looking okay. So, basically, I see
that, like,
the
okay. So
No. We deleted all these webhooks. I'm I'm
are these just filling up our event log
and really making things weird for us?
Oh, validating too.
Right.
Oh, okay. Look. There we go. Hot security
policy.
It's
just clogging up the logs. Yeah. So
Nice. That's I see that kavernal distraction as
Phil called it was actually hating and obfuscating
all the debugging stuff that we needed.
Alright. So Eric Hating Pods is forbidden.
Pod security, unable to admit pod empty. Okay.
There we go.
So we have
the RIC privilege policy. I think it's just
part of Rawkode and Seth. I think that's
okay.
I'm gonna assume this forty two one
which is such a random name is possibly
doing something a bit funky. Why do I
Describe that.
Yeah. Can
you do PSPs?
Let's find out.
Oh, you can. Nice. Okay. Okay.
So this is It
has a path prefix.
I wonder.
Will we just delete it?
Sure.
What does it belong to, though? Is it
is it managed by something? Who created this
pod?
There's Look at the namespace.
It's namespace.
There. It has no namespace. There's no metadata
on this which I think it just means
that bad actor has
decided to drop this in
and cause a little bit of carnage. So
I'm just gonna sledgehammer approach and we're gonna
delete that.
Okay.
Do we think we have a pod?
No.
Still no.
I'm wondering who created this
pod security policy.
There are some extra operators in here. Aren't
there?
Right here.
Cilium
operator.
Hubbell Relay
default.
Yeah. I want to know what the Cilium
operator does.
Maybe this is totally off.
So that manages the CNI plugins.
I see. I see. I see. Okay. I
think that should be all right.
Okay.
I wonder
that's the thing with this show like, you
think you're onto something and then nothing happened.
I'm
I'm going to delete the replica sets again
to try and Sure. Try and encourage your
pod to be recreated. Because if the pod
security policy did block it, the replication controller,
I'm not sure when it would try again.
That's fair.
No.
Alright.
Can we
describe the replica set
that we're getting? Yes.
Oh, we still have the pod security policy.
Pod security policy.
Replica set controller.
I didn't think those are
no. They're not named so
I wonder Well because these ones I saw
were okay and happy pod security policies are
actually
sneaky sneaky pod security policies.
So what are the caps there? I don't
know what that column is. I That's the
that's the capabilities,
Gavin. Yeah. See,
I see caps and I think capybar
That's just
please send me capybarra pictures on Twitter,
everyone.
Okay. So sysadmin,
Rawk privileged.
And then yeah. I don't know what's let's
let's describe those, I guess. Can we do
that?
Yeah.
Well, I mean, we could have, like, a
tape, but there we go.
Okay.
Run as any
manager
q CTL
client side apply.
Allow privilege escalation false.
Okay. Is this the one we're using, though?
Is this the one we're under?
What was the pod security policy? Hang on.
Let me scroll back.
Oh, gosh. I I scroll back, everybody.
No. No. When you scroll, it's it's it's
it's
you're scrolling as well? I was. Yeah. Looking
for any sort of hint.
Okay.
Pod security
policy.
Oh,
wait. From replica set controller,
can we, like,
can we get logs from the replica set
controller? Is that a thing?
Because I would like to figure out which
pod security policy is broken.
So
we could go and take a look
at the API server
I
think that would be a good idea.
Because Sledgehammer deleting pod security policies feels like
maybe now we're
we're removing
the debug abilities
since none of this gets exported to any
external logging system.
Okay. There's more Hiverno.
Yeah. Let's let's try and get Hiverno as
a picture.
Nothing. Okay. Why don't I just open it
and then
Okay. Alright. This seems to be all Kivera
now.
Authority set to yep.
Yeah. Like
Okay.
Alright. Let's just
clarify.
We have an API server. We got a
proxy. We got a schedule. Everything we expect.
Keyboard's running. It seems quite happy. It's it's
happy. We're communicating with the API server.
This is a permissions thing.
Yeah. For some wacky reason.
It's claiming a pod security policy was unable
to admit our pod even though we have
no pod security policy.
And
there's an empty
list.
Like,
it it feels like there is an error
message that's not that we aren't getting
at the end there.
Right? Unable to admit pod.
Yeah.
I'm
I gotta say, I'm feeling a little confused.
What's the
okay.
So
I don't know anything about pod security policies.
So I'm just going to Nor should you.
They're deprecated.
Which
which which Kubernetes version are we using?
One twenty,
I think. They're deprecated but not removed, but
they're still available at the moment.
Okay.
Let's see.
So this is our API server configuration.
Yeah.
We can disable
pod security policies.
Is that is that too harsh?
No.
No. Let's do it. We want this to
work.
Alright. Let's see if how that restarted.
QP API server.
Yeah. It did.
Make sure there's no I'm gonna give that
a second and check the pod again but
see if there's anything suspect
in here.
Do
you see anything?
Sorry. I know I'm scrolling fast but
that looks normal.
Yeah.
Maybe.
I love that everything I see is in
the form of a question without being a
question. Like, is it? Or
What's
a
what's the insecure port
thing?
I don't know. I think that can be
I think no. I don't think that does
anything anymore. I think insecure ports,
again, maybe Well, we have an insecure port
equals zero, and we have a secure port
equals six four four three. So I guess
I
hate this show.
What have I done? I broke the API
server.
Yep.
Shit.
Oh, wait.
Oh, is it restarting?
Oh,
I think because I dropped out of them
and it's just restart. Okay. Phew.
So
why
do we I'm also confused.
Why do we have
two roles on the API server? Is that
normal?
Which ones do you see?
Well, when we describe
when we when we describe the I'm sorry.
I just noticed that the Kube API server
also has is when you just describe the
nodes.
Every time I acquire them, it restarts it.
Oh,
sorry.
No. Off you go. You can type.
And I mean, maybe.
What?
What do we want? Yeah. Don't think it's
restarted yet.
Alright. We're get oops. Sorry.
We're
getting some advice from the audience here that
there was an alert privileged false flag in
the API server manifest,
which needs to be changed
to
a low privilege true.
So Okay.
Wait. So we're having too many privileges.
So a privilege true.
Yeah. I'm I'm actually not entirely sure.
I'm assuming the API server is saying that
we are low privileged pods.
I'm not entirely sure what that flag does.
I think I'll need to let the audience
tell us because I have no idea.
Oh, there we go. That was it.
Dang.
Alright.
So we'll give that a second.
So post the container image, we'll do our
upgrade and hopefully that is enough to get
us onto our second cluster.
So there was not a lot changed What
container creating?
Still sneaky. I'm
hoping it's pulling the image.
No.
Okay. Didn't we didn't we get that before?
We were seeing that with the Rawkode stuff.
But everything else seems
to oh, no. We we've lost this we've
lost our Cillium pods.
Oh, I'm such an idiot.
When we ran get pods in the Cilium
namespace earlier, there were only the two operators.
Right. Now it's just occurred to me that,
yeah, there was not actually any c and
I agents running on the nodes. And now,
I see one in an error state and
I'm even more worried. But
I should have picked that up.
Why did that fail?
They're
coming, maybe. No.
Enter.
Logs.
Let's see.
Could not open.
Subsystem,
read only file system.
So
what are the
system control
files here?
Not open. I p v four. I p
forward.
I p forward.
So
sounds like we need to
change the permissions on that.
What?
Let's
try
edit daemon set
cilium. I mean,
is that not a daemon set?
Oh, it's in the wrong namespace.
Edit.
It's
in the Cilium namespace.
Thank
you. I'm pretty sure I set that out
loud and I continued not to tape it.
That was useful.
Okay. What is going on with this demon
set?
Enable
debug false.
So maybe, first of all, we wanna enable
debug true.
That may may be healthy.
Wonder if these read only is true though,
should just be removed. I don't know. Yeah.
I I I I don't really know if
those are supposed to be
or not. That's the thing with this show.
People are cruel.
Like, what was the file system? Was it
The
there was a read only file system, but
the file system, I don't think were any
of these
paths.
Yeah. I don't think it was it. I
don't modules. Oh, wait. Tip Cilium config map?
No. But there were underscores
in the read only error. We can just
pull it up again, can't we? Let's get
Yeah.
Yeah. It's like, proc
sys net I p v four.
Wait. Disabled support for
due to missing kernel support.
I guess what we could always do,
I'm guessing.
Let's take a look at this filling and
config.
See if something in there has been changed,
not that I would even know that I
had.
So the operator should monitor this conflict map
and rule out the agents for us.
So, really, I guess, we just wanna see
I don't see anything. It's
monitor
aggregation interval.
No. That looks alright to me.
Yeah.
Sidecar
is still
Yeah.
I don't think
I don't think that's been touched.
So why is
I mean, the only reason that it could
write the process net
would be if it wasn't privileged.
Maybe we Do we have a Cilium config
map?
Yeah. We just that was the thing we
were just done. It doesn't really seem to
have too much in it,
which means we're kinda back to looking at
those redone lasers. Now
should we just remove them and just see
what happens?
Let's see. So this is the Cilium.
Sorry. I just did some I could just
redeploy Cilium.
Is that cheating?
I don't think so.
Alright.
Let's just do it.
Oh, I need to tell it not to
create the namespace.
Create namespace.
Okay. We'll just reapply it. We'll see what
happens.
Unchanged, unchanged. The operator was changed
and the demon set was changed. Okay. So,
something does happen
on those two. I'm curious if we edit
the daemon set now if those read only
file systems are still there.
They are. Okay. So something had changed in
here. Something had changed
in the operator,
And we're getting
running Acetym agents.
Yeah.
Good.
Phew.
I was getting panicked.
I'm curious what you changed, Phil. Feel free
to let us know in the comments.
So does that mean
Does that mean we have our pods?
Pending. That's different.
Right? Was that the same pod? Oh, no.
No. Pending. Yeah.
Okay.
Node role Kubernetes IO master.
Yes.
I was going to say here when we
did k get nodes.
I think I just
looked at it a little bit. But
see this?
Uh-huh. The control plane node has two roles.
Why does it need two roles?
And
Why does it need the master role? I
don't think it does need that.
I think that's the
a legacy thing because it was renamed from
master to control plane. So it's maybe just
left around because there's still things that depend
on that label being there.
But we're in Kubernetes one twenty. Seriously? I
So
Taint
zero to four nodes are available. Nodes one
node had taint,
but the pod didn't tolerate.
Okay. That's fine.
Three,
too many pods.
Too many pods?
Does that does it say too many pod?
Oh, okay. Yeah.
Ah. Rachel, let the
the pod
limit on the APIs or the Is it
the cubelet or the API server?
I don't know.
Let's find it.
I think it's the cubelet, but I'm gonna
check.
Yeah. Okay. It's not in here. Let's find
the cubelet.
So
the cubelet is starting for system d.
System
d.
Oops. Sorry. I'm about to drive.
Oh, no. You feel free if if you
wanna open the Qubelet. No.
Okay. So this just tells us where all
the configurations are. So we'll just pop these
open one by one.
Let's look at Q bled config.
Yeah.
Nope. That's just the
thing. Let's try this one.
Pod.
Anything.
Nope. Okay. Next.
Could be QPDM
flags.
No.
Which one did I miss?
Etsy default keyboard?
User bin
keyboard?
No.
Maybe it was that first one.
I must have missed one.
The
one for connecting to the cluster. The kubelet
we just opened, I've opened it three times
now.
The controller manager is not the one I'm
looking for.
It has to Why
am I so bad at this?
CD bar lib
kubelet
config.
Not there.
Maybe I just don't know what the flag
is called. Maybe I should just read them
all.
Can we restart the?
Yeah. But we need to find that config
first.
Are you sure it's max pods?
Unless it's not the kubelet under control. Oh,
I'm such an idiot again.
It's gonna be the kubelet on the worker
nodes. He's modified the kubelet on all the
worker nodes so that they can't run anymore.
I've joined another session if you wanna pop
over
hopefully.
I'm finally starting to come to my senses
a little bit here. There we go.
I
am having
super
I'm going to
drop off, I think, and reconnect because I
cannot see. It's very fuzzy. Your screen is
incredibly fuzzy. Right? Oh, no. Yeah. Feel free
to drop off. I'll some Be right back.
While you do that.
Perfect.
Var
lib
shiplit config.
Oh, a different number on each host. That's
fun. Thanks, Phil.
Welcome back.
Hooray.
I can see you.
Okay. I have removed all those very sneaky
max
pod settings.
And I'll probably need to restart the kubelet
on all of these.
We'd have to start stacking salt stack and
all these machines so this is easier.
Okay. All those kubelets now been restarted.
Uh-huh.
And
hopefully our pending
changes.
I hope so. I hope there's nothing else
on this cluster.
Failed to sync secret cache. Timed out waiting
for the condition.
I'm hoping those are old.
Yeah.
There
we go. Oops. Sorry. Off you go. I
would I won't touch the keyboard anymore.
It doesn't log anything. It's a it's just
a really Nice. Okay. Do you wanna modify
that deployment and change the version to v
two?
Which version?
On the image. So just k edit deploy
clustered.
API version.
No. Change it on the container image.
So we're gonna upgrade my application
so we can see my events.
I see. I see. I see. I see.
I see. Container image.
Yeah. There we go.
On help container registry.
My new favorite registry.
Uh-huh.
So we should be able to change that
v one to a v two. I'll put
forward from my local machine. We'll see the
dance, and we will move on to our
second cluster.
Thanks, Phil.
Let's dash f.
Okay. Our new version is almost running.
There we go. Okay. I'm gonna Ariminating?
Okay. I'm port forwarding.
I'm now gonna
one, Pat.
Something weird networking there.
No video supported. Well, we're not getting to
see my dance this time.
That's annoying.
Alright. Fixed. Let's move on to our second
cluster.
Alright. How was your first cluster?
Whoo.
Steve.
Alright.
Alright. Close all of my 14 tabs.
We're now on Cluster 12.
Thank you again, Phil.
For something that you said you'd went easy
on is, took us a little bit of
time to find what we got there.
Second broken cluster is by Guy Templeton who
is the co chair of SIC auto scaling
and an engineer at SkyScanner.
And happens to live very local to me.
Hey, guy. How are you doing?
I have created a Auto scam.
I've created a
teleport session on the control plane of Cluster
12 if you wanna pop over.
I will set up our cube controls
stuff for alias k.
I should really just bake these into the
image, shouldn't I?
Fascinating.
Is it broken again? Nope. Wait. I keep
doing I keep connecting to my own
session.
Alright. Here we are.
Maybe. It's thinking about it.
Oh, excellent. Hi.
There I am. I will give you the
honor of running k get nodes, get pods,
whatever you fancy, and see if we have
oh, two clusters of an API server.
People are being very kind.
Although at this point in time, I actually
think it's easier for me to debug the
API server than stuff Yeah. Yeah.
Alright.
Okay. So we're looking for the cluster deployment.
We are.
And that is running.
So is Postgres.
And there are some Smerle tools,
which what is Smerle?
I have no idea. I am gonna Let's
ask Google. Smerle.
Smerle, connected counters for social media.
Surprisingly powerful
communication
tools for your business.
I wonder why we have Smeril on our
cluster.
Sam count
display in real time is my first
result.
Alright.
Shall we
run get pods in namespaces and see Yeah.
Oopsies.
See if there's elephant's effect.
Ping back in and see some of those
logs. There's three completed jobs.
So
why are there jobs here?
There's this system,
cube scheduler,
speaker.
Okay. So this this looks like somewhat
less
terrifying.
We have a pending sleep pod. So that
just looks like something that is sleeping forever.
It does. And timing out due to, like,
health checks or something.
It's also the weird smell stuff, which probably
shouldn't even be there anyway.
Yeah. Let's do Let's describe the deploy
and see why there are extra pods in
it. Yes?
Yeah. Yeah. Why let's see why this one's
pending, I guess.
Oh, no.
Yeah. Custard is fine. It looked like it
was running.
Yeah. Should we just try and apply the
update?
Well, we should switch it to version two.
Maybe maybe this cluster's working.
Rolling update. Yeah. Yeah.
Sure.
Alright.
Progress deadline seconds. Oh, I can't scroll. Right.
Uh-oh.
Could not be patched.
Request is too large. FCD server.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
I don't like ETCD problems.
Deployments.apps
could not be patched. Request is too large.
So I'm wondering.
So
what what are these so we have these
extra pods in the namespace. Right?
How big are these pods?
And they've been sitting there. Right?
And the sleep pod
has a pending status.
No logs.
You may want to scrape it and see.
Yeah.
Exists tolerations.
Not ready. Execute exists
for OP. Exists for three three hundred seconds.
Okay. So five minutes.
Tolerations.
Unreachable. Execute.
Something tells me these are just noise to
get us looking at the wrong thing.
Maybe.
So when we try to modify the
clustered deployment with the new version of our
image,
we got an error from etcd
saying that the request was too large.
So Yeah.
I think we wanna go check
our etcd manifest
and maybe the STD logs.
Yeah. We should probably look at the STD
logs. Right? So
cool. Where do those live? Is it varloggedtd?
They'll be under varlogged
containers and then there should be an STD
file hopefully
in there.
Is it directory?
Yeah.
Yeah. That's the one.
Alright. Lots of hell.
Okay.
Wow.
I hit control c
just so we can
wow. Health okay. Okay. There's a ton of
health checks here.
Yeah. I
Somebody is sending so many health checks that
right?
There are like what?
Every ten seconds. Yeah. There's a health check.
Okay. That's okay though. That shouldn't
So I think this is
strangely Okay. Good because it means that STD
probably isn't broken and just misconfigured.
That's kinda what my hunch is So
why don't we jump into slash e t
c slash kubernetes slash manifests?
Kubernetes
every time.
And if we do
yeah.
Take a look at that cd.gam.
In fact, let's see if it's been modified.
Do I do a l s dash l
and see the timestamp on it?
Sure.
Oops.
I really hope it's been modified.
March 30
Yeah. Last night. '23.
Yeah. We see you guy. We know what
you're doing here. Alright. Let's pop this open.
And hopefully, it's as simple as a flag
he's passing them to restrict the size
of
the request.
Do you see it?
I hang on. Max request bytes
five.
Shall we just delete that line?
We can either delete it or make it
really big. I'm happy to delete it and
put it back if we need.
We'll remember my request by or comment oh,
no. If you yeah. Comment at it. Let's
do that. Good idea. Can we do that?
Does that even more how do we comment?
Oh, wait. Wait. Wait. It'll be a hash
symbol. Yeah. Or a pound Sorry. If you're
American, which well, the audience maybe.
Never understood. Oktothorp.
Oktothorp.
What? The German word?
No. That's the that's
saw you were telling me the German word
for, like, a pound symbol or some or
a hash symbol there. Yeah. The German symbol
for the pound is the same. Oh, alright.
The number.
The number's the thing.
Yeah. I only know this because my grandmother's
old recipes were still in pounds.
Got it. A German pound is 500 grams.
How much is a British pound?
I mean, like, the weight, not the money.
I have no idea.
I wish I knew that.
I'm gonna modify deployment just to see if
it works. Maybe this is gonna be nice
and simple.
I always say that was such hope.
Well,
the good news and bad news
It
saves get But it's not doing it. But
it didn't get edited.
So the edit does show it, but yeah,
we're not
Shall we redeploy it?
What possibly delete the pod first?
Yeah. Why don't we delete the pod and
then I reckon we're probably gonna have to
check
replicate could be the same problem as the
last one. Probably it could be
pod security policy or mutate webhook.
But let's delete the pods and see what
happens.
Hanging.
That should be okay. I think it's thinking
about it, hopefully.
I'm gonna control c it and just see
what's happening.
Yeah. I think it's trying. Okay. Why Terminating.
Why don't we Why is it
Why
is it terminating forever?
Either something It won't. Mess with again or
it's just being particularly slow.
Let's describe our replica set.
Okay.
No. We don't see anything here.
There's no PSP.
And I can never remember the mutated web.
I think this is the same as the
last one.
It feels like it. Right?
Sure.
It's not No. Well, it's a little different
though because the replica set, like, it's just
literally not
leaving.
Like, do we not have delete permissions?
Like,
why is it taking forever to terminate?
Don't do.
Okay. It's definitely Warning. Node's not ready.
From node controller. Node is not ready.
Let's let's
describe the nodes. Yeah. Good idea.
I
oh.
Yeah.
Alright.
So
these are all of the nodes.
Maybe I should just describe them in
in turn.
Non terminated pods, 15 in total.
What?
The kubel isn't posting node status anymore.
There's something wrong with the kubelet.
Do you see that?
Memory pressure. Kubelet stopped posting.
Yeah.
There's something wrong.
Okay. Which was also actually, the cubelet would
explain why we're not getting our new pod
created either because Yes.
It's just
well, it's running. There's that's a I guess
that's a star.
This is we're still on the API server
node.
Oh, yeah.
Why don't you hop over to the other
node and check on the cubelet?
Good idea.
Okay.
That's good. I guess if we can get
it working on one,
we should be able to see it. It
depends where it's scheduled. Let's check that first.
So get
oh, boy. So this terminating pod was scheduled
on
l zed. Is that the one I happen
to go on? No. Of course not. No.
Okay.
Let's go on to l zed.
And there's no kubelet.
Oh, that's not my it's a system
d service.
So
Yeah.
Exact start
is missing.
I don't know if the order there is
some No.
I don't like the look of that, so
I'm gonna remove it.
I don't want an enthusiastic star.
It looked alright. I would at least unless
it's crashing.
I see a status. Right? We should let's
trust system d.
Okay. It says oh, it's telling me that
it's been really Active activating
since Thursday
1810.
That is literally right now three seconds ago.
Right there. Active.
Keyboard service.
We just
Oh, yeah. Service has more than one exact
start setting which is not allowed. I just
removed that. Right?
Yeah. Why did
maybe my daemon reload didn't work.
And then restart Can you restart kubelet?
Unit kubelet service has a bad unit file
setting.
More than one exact star. Okay. So I'm
I'm
assuming
one of these other files.
There must be another system, the overlay.
There's a way to get that as well.
K.
You know, I think we need to like
stop
the cubelet first.
And then restart it?
Because
environment file.
There's a lot of environment file.
This drop in only works with cube, Adam.
K.
Okay. Let's stop to keep it.
Why does it keep Wait, I did modify
it. I put that exact start back in
because I wanted to confirm the message.
Stop kubelet.
Let's start kubelet
status kubelet.
How did I get that without the
pager?
Okay. So this is complaining now that
who knows? Let's go to logs.
Failed
code accident exception
failed. Oh, there's quite a lot in here.
Right?
Oh, god.
It just
speed up on our screen.
Go routine.
I don't see an
actual error yet.
And ah, there we go.
So the CPU, CPS quota period of one
second requires a feature set
feature gate to be enabled on the kubelet.
Okay.
So we can either enable this feature or
enable.
That makes sense? I I I don't know.
I've I've got Yep. Yep. I've got Kiplet
blindness now.
Yep. Let's go and add that custom.
Are you in this session?
I am. Sorry.
Maybe I am? Wait. Hang on. No. I'm
not in that session. Sorry. You're in the
node. I I haven't joined you.
LZ. Right?
Yes.
There we are.
Okay. That we broke. Okay.
We do have the CPUCFS
quota period.
Should we just comment that out?
Yep.
And
we'll restart.
Maybe that'll help.
Although I don't know if the fax is
just to disable the feature or enable the
feature gate, but we'll just we just wanna
get the system all running.
It's doing stuff.
Yeah.
Let me check on the other thing.
So,
on this side,
both Postgres and
our clustered workload are,
terminating.
Bunches of things are terminating.
Uh-huh. We are down to
pending.
Interesting.
We broke it.
Okay.
I'm
gonna check the kubelet on the last machine.
Did I join name two?
Eight nine.
No. Okay.
Let's just see if we have a kubelet
on here.
Yeah. We do have a kubelet. Okay. So
we now have a kubelet running on all
of the worker nodes.
However, we're still having a problems
terminating and scheduling
the cluster pod. Right?
Available.
Run get pods again or just does it
still just say terminating?
Oh, no. It's not.
Anything?
That that's better. Okay. So
why is Right. Postgres pending?
I
don't know. And oh, thirty four seconds.
You wanna try to describe and post this?
May maybe we're just being impatient. Maybe it's
it's coming back to life.
Every
time.
No events.
Absolutely no information there. State till set.
Node,
none.
Stat Oh, there's no scheduler.
Where did you see note none?
Note none. Right here. Oh, yeah. Yeah. Okay.
So Oh, sorry. I'm, like, highlighting it. Do
me use the screen sharing.
Yeah. There's no node, and there's no IP.
So we do have a scheduler running. I'm
gonna grab the logs of it.
Copy and paste.
Schedule appears to be okay.
Shoot.
Okay. So our schedule is running, but we're
not getting pods assigned to a node.
I'm not sure.
I'm looking at this.
And the the notes are reported healthy. Right?
Yeah.
What
about taints? Do the notes have weird taints
on them
We can that wouldn't allow us to schedule
things?
Invalid disk capacity.
Oh, yeah.
Good catch.
And then so note is now
so
So our Updated node
allocatable limit across pods.
K.
Sorry. What are you thinking?
Yes. So
when you pointed out the
valid capacity zero and image fail system, that's
obviously a
problem.
And that's on the
let's notice that.
L zed.
And the other one
oh, no. Wait. No disk pressure. Sufficient memory.
Okay. So the other nodes aren't reporting the
same.
But it's just that one node that seems
to be reporting that.
But that wouldn't explain
So it only happened once,
which means it's not recurring. It's not repeated.
Right.
Node has no disc pressure.
Five times two over
It's happened a couple times, though. I know
it has no disc pressure.
Right?
And it still has, like, non terminated pods,
Five in total. Okay. So there's five pods
on there. Yes. That makes sense.
Limits Thanks. Memory.
Julia, annoying me. So this is really weird.
Why are
so I'm looking at the allocated resources,
and
it's saying it's 0%.
Like, if you if you look at the
note description,
the request and the limits, like, 200
I mean, those aren't, like, super huge. Right?
But, like,
it's all 0%
of the note. Why? Is it just
does it just get, like
this looks really weird to me, but I
I I might not know anything. Like, CPU
requests are zero
for the cube system?
I think that's just because the resources that
are applied to the cluster are requested. So
small.
Resources. Okay. I'm not really doing Okay.
Sorry. I was I'm just looking at that.
00%
looks weird to me. In production,
I see, like, you know,
massive
percentages.
So like that. Okay.
So the thing that's really bothering me is
if we describe
in fact, we're not even getting yeah. Well,
let's describe the postage for And
and randomly these clusters died.
I mean, these pods, not clusters. Randomly, pods
just, like, went away
and
didn't come back
at all.
Like, not even pending.
Was
it? Yeah. Yeah. Okay. That's a good point.
Let's go back to our
we must be missing something obvious here, I'm
hoping. Let's describe this new replica set. Why
is nothing
happening here? Okay. So
this is very similar to the last cluster.
The pods aren't showing up. They're not being
created.
Let's check our events.
No. It is not ready.
It says and tool sleepy too. No. It
is not ready.
Tools.
No. It is not ready. And then post
pop
yeah. It all just says node is not
ready.
Node has sufficient
sorry. I'm just reading a starting Kubelet.
Why is the Kubelet starting
on that node?
Should we ask guys for some help
since we're approaching it? Like, look at the
logs on this replica set. Why is the
Kubelet not what why is that even on
there?
Invalid capacity zero on large file system.
Yeah. That's the batching guy. Scrolls. And how
does I never use the time.
I'm fine. Okay. My coworker,
who I'm supposed to be meeting with
in six minutes,
is currently waiting for his vaccine.
So he won't be there in six minutes.
So we just oh, we got the cluster
events. Alright. And then we started the kubelet.
Right? That was eight minutes ago.
We established
weird.
No. It's not ready,
but now
set up failed.
Failed mount.
Failed mount. There it is. Eight minutes twenty
four seconds.
Yeah. I see that. Killing. Stopping container tools.
Yeah. The whole note is not ready. That
one, we fixed. But,
the volumes
that are in the Postgres pod are
not valid.
And then there's a tape manager eviction
for the Smurl tools,
which I don't know that we need to
worry about those necessarily.
But let's fix the Postgres one first, which
is a
right there, taint man oh, it's also a
taint manager eviction right there.
And then a failed moan.
Oh, that's twelve minutes ago. But but yeah.
Where did you?
Twelve minutes ago, pod right. Slightly up. Marking
for deletion pod taint manager eviction. Why why
did it get
why is that a taint manager eviction?
We just tried to restart the
I don't see tint manager eviction.
Go up go up to go up to
two lines
twelve minutes ago.
Two lines from your highlight. Yeah.
Oh,
scroll
moving your cursor down, down, down. Oh, yeah.
Okay. Alright. There it is.
And there's a bunch of those.
And that happened when we deleted it. Why
does it report a paint manager eviction when
we
just wanted to delete the thing?
Didn't we just, like
we edited it. We edited the
let's look at the let's look at the
deploy description.
That could have gotten edited. Right?
I'm kinda worried.
I don't even know.
This header here seems really consistent, don't you
think?
Failed to set secret cache.
Yes.
Time to wait until the condition. Wait until
the condition.
What the hell is the secret cache?
I'm gonna Google this.
Yeah. Let's let's Google that message, actually. Good
call.
Beast me guessing for the next five minutes.
Partner is Rvac permission.
Joy.
Let's get ahead.
Are you there, Guy?
Forgot what's it. Latency. Oh, so they shouldn't
be because he's in the thing.
What is the point of a live audience
for support if they're not available there to
give you support?
Cassette.
Desired two, current one.
Yes. Thanks
for showing up.
This is all the slightly freaky with the
wait and see. Hang on. I'm gonna mute
the YouTube.
Alright. Give us a hint because
I'm over I
think I think you've got a bit
sidetracked on
the the errors and the events. There are
two
things
still going on here,
just to add to the confusion.
One
is why are pods stuck in pending and
not getting scheduled? You are on the right
tracks having a look at the scheduler.
I think you want to have a closer
look at it.
And the other,
you should see
once you fix it so it starts scheduling
pods.
Okay.
And was the CPU CFS quota thing being
commented out if I made that worse or
was that a fix?
No. That's fixed. I I was trying to
I I was trying to make a pod
a node very slow by putting the CPU
up really
CPU, CFS quarter window up really high.
The API server won't know.
Well, thank you for the hint. I hate
you. I'll speak to you later.
Thanks, guys. I don't hate you. This isn't
this is amusing.
I I I enjoy watching Scottish people hate
doing things because it's it's it's wonderful.
Okay.
So there's something
let's bake about our scheduler here. In fact,
yeah, we
I think if we in fact, we can
see here all these files have been modified.
So I'm not sure how we missed Yeah.
Air and air. So this is the scheduler
manifest.
Let's see if we can spot
Oh.
Special
scheduler?
I'm gonna remove that.
Thought We we should be overriding the scheduler
name.
Special as it might be,
not today.
Initial delay seconds,
time out seconds.
Okay.
Let's let's just change one thing at a
time though. Yeah. That's great advice. Definitely.
Although, I yeah. I I get a little
bit gun hold sometimes, so it's good to
change one thing at a time.
Alright.
Do we have a scheduler?
Maybe it just takes a minute. Alright?
We go.
Zero to one.
So that that affects our scheduling problem.
Maybe. If it comes Has
postgres
zero been assigned to node yet? No.
Okay.
So let's pull up the So maybe kill
the replica set. Kick the replica set.
Yeah. It's still not running though.
Yeah. It's not oh, yeah. It's not healthy
yet. So it may
so we just acquired the
leader lease.
So in theory,
this has been scheduled.
Alright?
Alright.
Cool. It has. Oh my gosh.
It's on that node too. Our favorite node.
Alright. So we'll override the scheduler name. Obviously,
I beg no no. We don't do that.
Sweet. So now we are still not seeing
Oh, sorry. On you go.
Clustered,
and we're not k. Describe.
Nope.
Okay.
Scaling replica set.
Scaled up replica set. One desired.
One available.
One unavailable.
Alright.
So
Yeah. I still think That's our that's our
clustered.
Yeah.
Check those replica sets again. I find it
really
weird that we're like, it's not like the
pod has been created and it's unscheduled. It's
just
there's just no pods. Right? And
Yeah. We're still
desired one on that second replica set. Okay.
So there's something wrong with the product. Wait.
What's happening here?
Three days, eight hours,
we have a replica set.
But the pod but it says desired and
current, but I don't see any current pods.
Yeah. I think he's What's happening there?
I think he's modified the controller manager,
and it's making all this
It's lying to us because I don't see
any pods.
What? It's not. No. You're right. Right. You're
right. So there must be something in here.
The fact that they could the fact that
the replica set isn't even creating the pod
for it to not be scheduled or rescheduled
is a big warning sign.
So
what has our sneaky Scottish person done in
here?
Look at all those controllers listed here.
That's a large attack surface
to change stuff.
What else is there? Can I scroll?
No.
Maybe I can't. No. That's right. Oh god.
Weird. That's
I'm good at them. I promise.
Okay.
What's happening down here?
Scheme, h t t p s port.
That seems fine.
So
I I think it's the that controller's list.
One of the weird things you can do
with Kubernetes is I only know this because
of an earlier episode
is is
that
you can do weird shit like, you know,
disable the replica set controller and stuff.
But one of the other things is you
can just tell it to run them all
like this. So I think he's purposely
typed all of these out to kinda hide
the fact that the replica set controller is
missing.
And in fact, if we set
there is a replica set replication controller.
Replication.
Is that same?
No. I think
let's say that. Let's do the star.
Like, what's the what's the worst that can
happen? Let's let's try and let's try and
spin up a version.
I mean, somebody could later take over this
cluster after you deleted it from
Well,
there is that. I'm gonna I'm gonna ignore
that. We just I didn't that wasn't me.
And then I'll do my impatient thing when
I run PS every fourteen seconds or every
fourteen milliseconds. Okay. We have a controller manager.
And I better see a pod in a
second.
I wonder if we should delete like build
replica sets and try and encourage it to
Yeah. I was thinking that.
Although, why is there an ancient replica set?
It's gone there. Oh.
Oh. And we have a Okay.
Look at that. Wow. And it's talking about
terminating
pods.
It's terminating pods that don't exist?
Interesting. We didn't know about before.
Alright. So that's the hopefully, that's now pulling
the image.
And it's running.
Wait. It is running.
Alright.
Let's go into Oh,
yeah. Did we deploy our update? I can't
remember. Yes. Oh, we we tried to. Right.
Okay. So we can port forward
cost.
There we go. It should be edited.
Yeah. I think it was one of the
first things we did and then we realized
that everything was broken.
Yes.
Although we have a second.
At least like we have a second problem
though. And that Oh, no. Wait. It it
can't hit the database service.
So there's potentially one more problem or maybe
it's unrelated.
So I'm just gonna describe the service and
see if we have any endpoint.
Shit. We do.
Is this an intended guy before I start
Wait. Let's let's double check let's double check
that we did in fact
edit the deploy.
Yes.
Oh, yeah?
Okay.
Okay. So why
can it not speak to a database?
Yeah. It definite it definitely can't speak to
a database.
Let's look at the logs.
I don't think there are any. You can
try. What?
It's a very terribly written Rust application that
I wrote. So
Oh, I mean, I wonder if it can't
connect because
they're out of sync.
It looks like it's DNS.
It's always DNS. Right? It says failed to
look up address information, name not found. So
let's check Kube DNS is working. Do you
wanna run a get pods on the Kube
system namespace?
Have to DNS is running.
Well,
why do we need
to
So DNS is really bad for logging. In
fact, I don't expect to see anything come
out of that container. But it also says
not found.
Oh, you're it's just missing the cube system
namespace flag.
Ah, right. Thank you.
I'm like, it's broken.
Right? Okay.
I'm I'm losing I lost
I lost connection here. Ah.
Wait. Maybe?
Go ahead. You type. Yeah. Was just gonna
say it's a lot easier to spot tables
than missing words when you're not the one
typing.
No. I lost connection to the
I think I Oh, sugar. My
Alright.
Connection refused.
Failed to watch
v one service unknown.
Get namespaces.
So it looks like it is
trying to speak to the
API server.
I'm getting connection refused.
Maybe
not. I don't know if there should be
a selector on that service. Let's describe the
service.
Yeah. Okay. So it's it's fine.
There is an endpoint. The service is available
on port four four three.
Why can core DNS
not speak to our API server? Because core
DNS never talks to anybody.
What?
Okay. So this is a Selium cluster.
Okay. Which means
there are no network policies. Okay. Sugar.
Why are there two
pods
for cordianess?
Why are there two cordianess pods? It just
runs for redundancy.
That should
be okay.
Maybe.
Okay. So
core DNS
has a pod. It's scheduled. It's running. It
has no connectivity across the cluster.
Shit.
And there's a connection refused. If it's not
a network pause, it may be
either kip proxy or
the core DNS deployment could have been modified
in some way.
Okay.
When was it edited last? How would we
know that?
Is it in the manifest?
Yeah. If we do a
if we do a cube edit deployment
cube dash n cube system core DNS, we
should be able to look at the metadata
or status that may have a data in
it.
Failing that, I think we're gonna have to
either look at
yeah. I mean, it could even be IT
tables. It depends how
evil Guy was feeling.
Yeah. So there's a generation four
on this. So I think it has been
modified.
Replicas to
generation four?
Tell me more about that.
Oh, revision four. Yeah. Every time we modify
it, the generation Creation time stamp. That was
two days ago, though.
03/29.
I'm just scrolling and hoping something jumps out
at me. Schedule new name is the default
scheduler priority class name system cluster critical.
I don't know what that means.
Okay.
I wish I had an idea.
That's
weird.
No events on that? The endpoint is a
public
IP address?
Get I
I don't think it should be.
So if we do a get pods
wide
our IP server has.
There's the one forty five though down there.
Packet cloud controller manager
and cube proxy.
Okay. So some of them are getting.
Okay. Wait. Wait.
Okay.
So wait.
Wait. Hang on. The
cube proxy
for the
cluster that we were trying to schedule on,
L Z 6 N Q,
am I am I, like, super
out of whack here?
Because
that is the only one that doesn't have
a public IP.
I'm
I'm just
sorry. Like like, right on the third one
from the bottom. Right?
But the one right above it is the
other worker node, and it has a public
IP.
Okay.
So you're So the service
let's look at the service, the Kubernetes service.
I think wait. Kube proxy, right, on the
broken node.
Are we on that node? No. We're not.
We're on the control plane node. So I
think So we should look.
See that?
I I think these are okay and these
why
does our core DNS have a different
structure? Why is it a 19216845?
That's
not a CIDR address that we're using in
our cluster. Right? Like,
our pod IP space is 1012.
The public IP address is I think is
typically okay.
This is fucked.
Right. And
also but, like, I bet we can't reach
that particular node because it also doesn't have
I should be better at this by now.
So right now my hypothesis is that the
IP address of these pods
has been
some something ski with there. Right? That that
shouldn't be the IP address of those pods.
So
Yeah.
I
I don't know.
Why is it getting those IP addresses?
Let's kill them. How'd you feel about that?
That sounds great.
And see if it comes back with those
funky IP addresses again.
I I
I'm too quick to delete pods. I know
it's a terrible practice but sometimes I think
just let's
just do it.
Okay.
So it has come back with those IP
addresses.
Now if it's on a if it's on
a a network of its own, it's not
gonna be able to reach
the IP address of anything that within the
cluster.
Like it just wouldn't have the roots
at all.
So what
So what is the
I'm having to just to delete all these
the shit and the default namespace that we
know shouldn't be there.
Unless you've you've got some
ideas. I'm drawing a loss again.
Is it
You happy with that?
Yep.
Oh, no. Wait. They're
of course, they're deployments.
Okay. Good. Gone.
Let's wait for them to go away.
The only
I I don't even know. I'm completely guessing.
I think hopefully we can delete core DNS.
I I don't think those IP addresses or
ranges. I think something's messing with it.
We did look for admission controllers
earlier.
Well, I mean, we also have no
trouble.
Wow. There's like,
it's telling us twice that it is terminating.
Look at that. For the same one.
See that?
The the the the deletion log is weird.
Yeah. But I just blame Kubernetes for that.
Yeah.
I'm gonna delete this and then you're on
your own. I have no idea. I'm just
gonna I
wanna see core DNS come back with an
IP address that I know exists in my
cluster.
No. Okay.
So the CNI plugin is responsible for giving
everything an IP address.
Let's check the
So then config map.
There
Oh, there's a cluster at P V 4
Pool Of 1921680016.
Is core DNS I don't know what that
means.
Means I may have done something very bad.
Shit.
I think
he's changed the cider of our network
at Medflight.
Like, right now?
Okay.
I
just I I I
I'm
so mad at When when I see a
get pods all
and I'm seeing 10.12
here,
I'm seeing 1 9 twos here. Are these
node related?
Let's do a grep for 89.
Wait. What did I get? Oh, that's it.
Silly.
Okay. So this is all of our pods
with IP addresses.
I'm gonna grep on a worker eight nine.
Nothing. That's not right.
Oh, no. A dash a 89.
Yeah. See, we have multiple
CIDRs across
I mean, that just seems fucked.
So let's check out I don't know if
you're still watching my screen or if you're
watching my screen or if you're on your
I am. Alright. Okay. So Yeah. I'm gonna
pop open Versus Code, and then I'm gonna
remember which CIDRs are used for cluster creation.
So here's
the no. Cluster dot YAML.
Oh, there's gonna be a token in here,
but we're just we'll deal with it.
I'm super out of my depth here. Cider
blocks.
Yeah. Okay. So 192168.
I weirdly
enough then.
However
That that looks right then.
But only for core DNS and a few
other things. We have a whole bunch
of other stuff on its own network.
Right.
I don't know.
So
we just we're gonna have to just check
all the obvious stuff then.
Cluster size Oh, service cluster. Service
cluster IP range.
down there.
Service cluster IP address range.
I don't know what that means, but I
all all I see is different. It's different.
I think that's just for Kubernetes
and core DNS. I'm not even sure.
Okay. Okay. I'm confusing myself. That was wrong.
10 or 12 is the actual bare metal
network. So I'm going to describe this pod.
I bet you it's just got
both.
Rawkode.
Is it just got multiple IP addresses and
get pods that's just pecking a random one
to show me?
No. That's it's only IP address. Which means
it's either running a host networking or doing
something else. So I think that's a completely
different thing, and I'm debugging the wrong problem.
So
which is very standard.
So now back to this. Core DNS cannot
speak to the Kubernetes API server.
It's getting a connection refused. I don't think
it's our back. It literally cannot hit
the service. We've checked the service. It has
endpoints. They look alright.
What about the cube API server?
Yeah. Let's check.
Because that one has been up forty three
hours,
which is not the same time as when
the cluster was made.
Well spotted.
Okay. So
I mean, we could just look at this
as a static manifest. I shouldn't look at
it in the cluster.
So we're back to suspecting something in here.
Mhmm.
Kubernetesdefault.service.cluster.local
is a service account.
Do we have it?
Why?
Does that make sense?
Why does a keyblade have a preferred address
type?
Enable admission plugins, node restriction.
Is that normal?
Yes.
I've fallen for that before. I tried to
delete it, and it turns out that is
normal. Normal. What about the advertised add address?
Yeah. I'm looking at that. So
we wanna correlate that to the service IP
address. Right now, I'm gonna assume it's okay.
But definitely something I'm gonna check-in a moment.
The rest of this looks fine. I mean,
we're speaking to the API server. Right? It
it it is working.
Controller and other server seats are scheduling pods.
They're speaking to it. It's
only Yeah.
It's only core DNS.
Is there something funny about core DNS?
Yeah.
Let's go back into this. I feel like
we've missed something. I've missed something.
Oh, I missed something too.
So
where are we in right now? This is
the
core DNS
config.
I'm really looking to see if this
networking stuff
is wrong.
Now he could have changed the security context.
I'm not sure what core DNS needs, but
I'm assuming that being service is probably alright,
etcetera and all. It doesn't run a DNS
server.
But it drops all?
The DNS policy yeah. That should be alright.
Although, I think there is a DNS policy
of host firewall. Wait.
Wait.
Okay. So default is not the default.
You know what we could do?
CoreDNS
Kubernetes
manifest.
What's this supposed to look like? And you
can see I've been on this before because
clearly people keep fucking with CoreDNS.
But
so what was it we said was potentially
suspect? We wanted to look at
DNS policy.
Yeah. Default seems to be okay. Okay. That's
fine.
What was the other thing? I'm not sure
about enable service links. That sounds bad to
me. Yeah.
Because that would imply that it's maybe
yeah. I don't There's something that's missing. Priority?
What about priority?
Two
bajillion?
That looks huge. What
is that even?
It's not set in here,
but the priority class name is. So, yeah,
let's let's comment that. The class name seems
okay. Preemption policy
isn't set so we're gonna take that out
too.
Schedule the name security context.
Like you said, let's change one thing at
a time. Let's let's see if any of
that
helps us whatsoever.
I really wanna be on the viewer side
of this one one week. Right? I just
not be on the side of it for
sure.
I'm gonna have to get someone else to
host this.
Okay. So we're deleting core DNS. I'm hoping
this is the enable service links or that
priority crazy big number whatever that's doing.
Maybe guy would join us if it fixes
it and tells what the hell that was
doing.
Let's
see if I can port forward again.
I just forget maybe it's still broken.
Should we
restart the whole Kubernetes deployment rather than just
delete the pods?
Well, let's check the logs of it first
in case of something. Sure.
No. It's healthy now. Whereas I was complaining
a lot last time, wasn't it?
I don't remember.
It was. There were
We deploy
our clustered deployment.
Yeah. Okay. So it can pick up on
things. I I just like starting with a
fresh slate sometimes.
Yeah. I'm just gonna check both of these.
Yeah. Those both look good. So let's try
your suggestion.
Actually, just like
delete the whole deploy, like, redeploy it.
Okay.
Well,
since it's up, I'm gonna just check it.
See what happens.
Yeah, we still have no cluster DNS.
Kubectl s has endpoints. I'm assuming Kubernetes has
endpoint.
Are they scheduled on different nodes?
Okay. That's after eight.
Yeah. Let's see if Guy wants to come
back and give us last bit of advice
before we we wrap this up. Yeah.
You there, Guy?
I am indeed.
Very close.
You've you've not looked at the configuration of
core DNS. You've looked at the pods, but
not how the pods are configured to run
the DNS.
Okay. So the
you want us to look at the core
DNS conflict map?
Yeah. And you can
I I nicely left you some small tools
pods so that you could if you didn't
have anything in the cluster to exec into
and run decks against things in the cluster
and outside the cluster, you could use that?
You didn't seem to like my present much.
I
I didn't know where Smurl was. I just
was like, hey, go away.
Because in in my experience of these episodes,
people don't leave me helpful things. They leave
me bad nasty things. And I just wanted
rid of anything I didn't know what it
was. So
I mean, that's that's reasonable.
Alright. Thank you. We'll give this another few
minutes to see how we get on. Thanks,
guy.
I
like my phone a friend button. That's coming
in quite handy. Okay.
Unfortunately, we had this YAML open so why
don't we
go through the config map? So we're looking
to see
errors
of
ready. So I'm I'm I'm I'm impressed to
see that lame duck is a real thing.
Great.
Kubernetes cluster dot local.
That's different. Cluster domain reverse
sliders. Yeah. I think these are
substituted
apply
time. Oh, sure. Sure. Sure. So that's fall
through.
We've got bad stuff here.
Do we? Oh, TTL.
And TTL. Yeah. Let's get rid of those.
Is there anything else?
Prometheus forward cash flow. Prometheus
forward cache list reload load balance reload load
balance.
Yep.
So I just like What about forward at
c resolve con?
Yeah. I think that's just telling it to
fall back on Yep. Both.
Okay. So now we've modified a config map.
There's no core DNS controller. We will need
to put those pods.
And then let's just hope it fixes it.
It's always this slow. I should start doing
a force kill with a grace period on
it.
I hate config maps.
Just I
really just don't like them. I'm like, no.
I don't think that helped.
Well
Okay.
While he told us to try that, let's
try it.
I guess that's the nicer way instead of
deleting the pods.
But we already deleted the pods and we
still weren't getting the work in DNS.
Although I guess the server never really checked
to check the service was actually responding yet.
Bad me.
Okay, we have endpoints.
We have put DNS.
Yeah.
Just keeps coming. Alright.
Did we miss something?
Is that errors supposed to be at the
top? Yeah. Errors.
Health lame doc. Ready
Kubernetes.
I wonder if this lane is wrong.
Is it custard at local dot service?
Oh, no.
Let's let's I'm gonna see cheat. Let's I'm
gonna jump on to cluster 14
and grab the config map and see what's
different. Yeah.
I don't need an invite. There we go.
Okay.
You think after seven episodes, I would know
what this config map is supposed to look
like, but I just
do not.
Have cube control,
cube config.
Okay.
This one works. Cool. Cluster dot local. Oh,
and the pod and secure and the TTL
are actually there too.
The forward.
This is the same contact now.
Right? Right?
Yeah. I think so.
Let's pull them side by side.
It was in the same.
And put the lane one.
Yeah. So we had to move to polygen
secure
and TTL. So let's add that back.
Sure.
What about
Yeah. These are the exact same fail. So
he told us to look in the core
DNS config and then there is nothing wrong
with the core DNS config. That's just cruel.
Yeah.
Alright. What about the
You got an idea?
Okay. I'm I want to get
seriously.
K.
Guy has given us a helpful hint on
the YouTube chat saying there's a few pixels.
This is a white space error in the
core DNS config. I will be
mighty frustrated.
Do you mind if I
Cool. I don't know. Go for it. Yeah.
Go for it. No. Just feel free to
open it. Do the thing. Yeah. Okay. Let's
just pull up in that config map again.
Unless it's whatever's off screen.
No. There's nothing.
Wait. Hang on.
Which one's the so this is 14.
Okay. So this one's 14 here.
And in fact, I'll I'll explain it.
Might not be a white space error,
and this is 12.
K. Resource version
is different.
Uh-huh.
K. Flip back to 14.
Keep flipping.
Scroll up.
Okay.
Scroll up to where it says data core
file.
Damn.
He's mocking us now because he said you're
jumping back and forward showed a slight difference.
This number seems arbitrary. Oh, you're rich.
That's the one that's so different. And I
was looking at the time stamp. So that's
The res the UID is different, and the
resource version is like
So the resource version, I would expect different,
but it's wildly high. Right?
Yeah. But what I don't even know what
resource version means
in this case.
Is this a
where does that come from? Could fig map
resource version? I'm gonna delete it and see
what it puts in its place.
Yeah. Our big huge number.
Okay.
Six digits.
Did you just replace it with the previous
one or with the one from the other
cluster?
I'm I'm just gonna look up wait. What
the
I don't even know what that means, resource
version.
I'm assuming.
There's like a weird bug and I'm sure
he's found it because he works at Skyscanner
and they've got a level of scale that
most people don't have.
But
something to do with this number going so
high is maybe causing it to load an
old config map in the pods or
something. I don't really
know.
But the number being so high worries me.
But we're now at the stage where I
have to go and pick up my daughter.
So
Yeah. I'm just gonna bring Guy in to
tell us what wonderful magical What we should
this is. Yeah.
Alright, guys.
Lay on us.
So
when you were jumping back and forth between
the working config and the
non working config,
If you look really hard at the c
in front of it in the Kubernetes config
Oh, you bastard.
The c?
Yeah. It's not a c.
No. It's a it's a character which looks
a lot like c.
What? So the Kubernetes plug in became authoritative
for
letter that looks like cluster.local.
That is cruel.
Yeah. I'm feeling a bit bad about it.
And it works.
I mean, my app doesn't work, but it
worked.
Alright. That was really harsh, guys. Thank you.
Sorry.
I think I only need my best to
meet
the person.
Alright.
I really
really do have to go get my daughter
before she gets really grumpy that she's not
in her bed.
Guy, I'm gonna cut you off but thank
you very much. That was painful.
Thank
you.
I learned a lot.
Okay.
This was really this was really fun. Thank
you so much for having me.
I'm I learned a ton. I hope I
was helpful.
Yeah. You were. You definitely were. It's always
nice just to have somebody help you, talk
to you.
We've got some really good tips from you,
you know, changing one thing at once. Just
walking through the whole process. And again, we
have to make sure that people know that
doesn't matter how much you work with Kubernetes
day and day. There's just so much. It's
such a huge complex project with thousands of
contributors, millions of lines of code.
You don't need to know all. So
You just need to have friends
to jump on clusters with.
Sadly. Friends like Gwen to come and help
you whenever you need it. So
This was super fun. Yeah. Thank you for
joining me. Have a a really great day
and I will speak to you again soon.
I will. Enjoy bedtime.
Bye.